[Musique]
regardez ce qui est arrivé dans cette
boulangerie parisienne c'était il ya
quelques jours elle a écopé de quinze
jours de fermeture administrative car il
avait vendu quelques baguettes alors
qu'ils étaient en train de nettoyer la
boulangerie aux environs de 18h30 est un
client qui c est qui s'est pointé on lui
a permis d'acheter une baguette la
police était là quinze jours fermeture
administrative situation est toujours
très tendue à trappes autour du maire de
la ville ali arhab et bénéficient à
présent d'une protection policière après
kate a même été ouverte pour des menaces
de mort à son encontre après un
signalement
autre information absolument surréaliste
un collectif de bénévoles c'est qu'ils
font des maraudes pour distribuer des
repas chauds aux sans abri et ils ont
été dispersés par la foule dispersée par
la police pardon parce qu'il y avait une
foule qui s'était forcément réunies
il était en train de donner à manger il
a dit simplement dépassée l'horaire du
couvre-feu
un maire qui défend sa ville il ne nie
pas les difficultés qu'il y attrape
mais il rappelle avec justesse à quel
point les maires aujourd'hui sont les
poilus de la république mais également
dans les banlieues évidemment rien n'est
perdu et il se passe des très belles
choses à trappes trap est une ville dans
laquelle la région s'investit énormément
et la patronne du rassemblement national
il faut mettre la ville sous tutelle
c'est un territoire perdu pour la
république sous le poids d'une
immigration massive et ininterrompue
qu'il a changé en profondeur
monsieur darmanin qui lui dire vous
n'êtes vraiment pas suffisamment ferme
vis-à-vis de la laïcité enfin on croit
rêver
on croit rêver et si vous pensez que
avec ce cours des choses
on n'avance pas vers une société pré
fasciste alors vous vous trompez
l'élection de marine le pen on le sait
tous est une possibilité
c'est une possibilité politique elle
doit donc être combattue combattu avec
des idées qu'on bâtit des convictions
combattu avec des résultats combattue
elle des hommes et des femmes qui
s'engagent
quand tu lui reprocher la mollesse
c'était pour dénoncer au fond ces
discours variable selon l'endroit où
elle est quand même là mais elle se
cherche effectivement une respectabilité
mais le fond c'est ce qu'elle représente
ce qu'elle est depuis des années
ce foyer familial dans lequel elle vit
et dans lequel elle puise tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui me fait penser qu'elle est
une ennemie de la république beaucoup de
médias ont aidé mal à me le pen a
présenté son programme de
dédiabolisation
mais moi je n'y ai jamais cru quand tous
les chiffres sont faux 7e une monteuse
incompétente
tous les chiffres et pas rien entre
monsieur darmanin qui trouve sic
madame le pen trop molle non pas sur
l'islamisme mais sur l'islam et monsieur
castaner deux jours plus tard qui dit
que c'est une ennemie de la république
vous voyez bien qu'il ya un cynisme au
plus haut niveau de l'état qui est bas
un coup on envoie castaner braquer la
gauche le coup on envoie darmanin
barragué la droite et l'extrême droite
dans un débat pour la pour la
déstabiliser ça n'a pas marché
vous savez on va pas faire un concours
de savoir qui est mou qui est dur qui
est plus dur 57 voix contre 43 la
majorité n'est pas atteinte
soulagement dans le clan trump nous
avons plaqué nos détracteurs au sol et
nous avons remporté cette affaire il n'y
a plus de combats nous avons gagné non
coupable tous ces lâches
tous ces sénateurs qui n'ont pas pu
regarder en face ce que le président a
fait et les enjeux pour notre pays
la cour suprême du québec vient de
décider de bannir du code civil les mots
femmes/hommes mères et pères au prétexte
qu'ils sont discriminants à l'égard des
personnes qui refusent d'appartenir à un
sexe plutôt qu'à un autre on les appelle
les noms binaire nouveau genre humain
marseille oui hier des salariés d'une
chaîne de burger ont manifesté contre
leur tenue de travail
au dos de leurs tee-shirts portés
notamment par des jeunes femmes pendant
le service des slogans comme à poil et
d'inde ou encore il faut se farcir ce
qui aurait valu des remarques obscènes
et salaces de la part de clients donc là
bas les enfants n'auront plus ni maman
ni papa ni mère ni peur mais une
filiation c'est plus moderne